today on the matt wall show we finally
descended upon loudoun county yesterday
my my new home to make our voices heard
though the school board threw every
possible roadblock in the way we'll talk
about some of those today but the
loudoun county situation is part of a
larger and more important conversation
about who exactly should be determining
what our kids are taught in schools the
state or the parents we'll discuss that
also the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff is asking what is asked why he
won't resign for his failures in
afghanistan his answer is less than
sufficient i think greta thuneberg
babbles incoherently and receives
raucous applause and a black teacher in
california is not pleased with the
special gift basket she was given for
being black and then will smith says
that his open marriage with his wife is
perfect and loving and beautiful and
somehow i doubt that we'll talk about
all that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well when i set out on my journey to my
new home here in virginia uh you know
the first thing i made sure to pack that
was my trusty relief band i never go
anywhere without it relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea wrist
band that's been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraine
hangover morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsy and provides
all-natural relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea from patients but now through a
leaf band it's available to the masses
how it works is relief band stimulates a
nerve in the wrist that travels to the
part of your brain that controls nausea
then it blocks that signal
and that your brain is sending to your
stomach telling you that you're sick and
relief ben is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics to treat
nausea and vomiting and i tell you this
thing really does work ensure that
nausea is never the reason to miss out
on life's important moments right now
relief band has an exclusive offer just
for matt walsh listeners if you go to
reliefband.com and use promo code walsh
you'll receive 20 off plus free shipping
and a no questions asked 30-day
money-back guarantee so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com
and use promo code walsh for 20 off
well it was a long time coming not weeks
but really years in the making as i have
uh revealed to you in some vulnerable
and emotionally honest moments on this
show recently that i have long desired
to be a resident of the state of
virginia i've always felt deep down that
i really was virginian even back when i
was living a lie
identifying with the state that was
assigned to me at birth but finally
yesterday i was able to make the
official transition and become a legal
resident of virginia when i signed a
lease to rent a woman's basement for uh
one dollar a month it was a little more
than i wanted to spend but i decided to
splurge a little bit and it was worth it
because i'm now at peace with myself i
feel at home in my body and in my state
and even more importantly yesterday we
had our rally at the loudoun county
school board in protest of their radical
indoctrination of the kids in the
district
uh the turnout was incredible the energy
in the crowd made it feel even bigger
than it already was
uh unsurprisingly also none of the
opposition showed up after sending me
threatening messages for weeks i showed
you some of that some of the things they
were
saying to me some of the threats they
were making
they all chose to stay home cooking up
their next batch of mean tweets and
disgruntled emails i guess this is a
common theme for people on that side
they'll confront you online
maybe they'll confront you in real life
if they can be confident that they'll
have you entirely outnumbered but
outside of that
they prefer to stay hidden in the
shadows and insulated
this is especially true of the loudoun
county school board itself
i did end up speaking before the board
and we'll play that clip in a moment but
consider the hoops we had to jump
through just to earn an audience with
the royal majesties on the school board
as has been much publicized they
required proof of residence no problem
for me as a man who has been a virginia
resident
since you were in diapers
i mean if you're currently still an
infant then that would be true um we had
to also present uh you know we had our
proof of residence we had to present
outside the building and they also
demanded that we show our ids as well
and then next we had to empty our
pockets and undergo a tsa style security
screening
already the process to speak at a school
board meeting a public school school
board meeting is far more involved and
far more secure than the process to vote
and the whole thing felt quite racist to
me frankly because it certainly would be
called racist if they required all of
that outside of a voting booth
and we aren't done yet because next we
were ushered into the mostly empty
building
and i also have to say the building
where the school board in loudoun county
does its business is enormous like the
size of the pentagon
um
no spectators were allowed to sit inside
the room with the school board no one no
one could be
in the presence of their highnesses
no one in the public was permitted to
attend the public meeting
some media were allowed inside but most
were outside the building and we were
then told to stand once we got inside we
were ushered along we were told to stand
in certain marked areas six feet apart
single file waiting for our name to be
called
at which point we would have exactly 60
seconds to give our comment
at 60 seconds a buzzer sounds and the
mic is cut off and for a final indignity
and the thing that i hated the most you
had to wear a mask
no mask no mic that was the policy
all of this again to speak at a school
board
of course as we're standing in the
hallway waiting to be brought before the
royal court we could hear one peasant
subject after another get up there
barely articulate a complete thought
before being buzzed and kicked out of
the room
the school board said before my arrival
the school board said that that i was an
outside agitator and they didn't want me
there because they really wanted to hear
from the parents of loudoun county and
other community members
well that's kind of funny because if
they really wanted to hear from the
community they have a they have an odd
way of showing it
they want to hear uh from the community
for exactly 60 seconds a piece to be
specific
which means of course that they don't
want to hear at all because unless
you're a very polished speaker
and you do these things professionally
you will not be able to say anything of
substance in one minute put on the spot
like that the people who go to school
boards
for the most part are not professional
speakers it shouldn't have to be
that's what made the whole thing a farce
though that isn't even the worst of it
standing in line with the other
community members
i was informed that in the past the
school board has set the time limit for
public comment to 30 seconds
that's only enough time to basically
tell the school board to kiss your ass
which the next time they set it to 30
seconds that's exactly what every person
in line should do they should have 300
people signed up and every single person
just get up there and say you know what
kiss my ass
anyway finally it was my turn with 60
seconds on the clock and a mask muzzling
my face and here's what i had to say
i would thank you all for allowing me to
speak to you tonight but you tried not
to allow it yet here i am now you only
give us 60 seconds so let me get to the
point you are all child abusers you prey
upon impressionable children and
indoctrinate them into your insane
ideological cult a cult which holds many
fanatical views but none so deranged as
the idea that boys or girls and girls
are boys by imposing this vile nonsense
on students to the point even of forcing
young girls to share locker rooms with
boys you deprive these kids of safety
and privacy and something more
fundamental too which is truth if
education is not grounded in truth then
it is worthless
worse it is poison you are poison you
are predators i can see why you try to
stop us from speaking you know that your
ideas are indefensible you silence the
opposing side because you have no
argument you can only hide under your
beds like pathetic little gutless
cowards hoping we shut up and go away
but we won't
i promise you that
thank you for your time and i'll talk to
you again very very soon
now there's more that could have been
said obviously but those were the bullet
points
the spectacle inside the building was uh
pathetic and and pitiful in in many ways
because of all of this
all of these uh these uh
roadblocks and everything that were put
in our way but it was also a good sign
in another way
because the board was doing all of this
because they're scared and they're
scared and they should be scared because
they realize that they no longer have
free reign to do whatever they want to
do
enact whatever policies they want to
enact
impose their value system on kids
without pushback or consequence
and that's what this whole debate is
really about if you can call it a debate
with the way they've set it up
it was actually it was thrown into sharp
relief during the virginia gubernatorial
debate which as it happens was taking
place
during the meeting not far away so so
not far away from where we were they
were having the um
gubernatorial debate between tara
mcauliffe and glenn youngkin and when
the topic of education came up terry
mcauliffe the democrat had this to say
listen to this the parents had to write
to veto bills veto books glenn not to be
knowledge about it also take them off
the shelves and i'm not going to let
parents come into schools and actually
take votes out make their own decision
you vetoed it so
yeah my parents stopped the bill that i
don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach let's you
know i get really tired of everybody
running down teachers i love our
teachers and what they have done through
covid these are real heroes that deserve
our respect and you keep running them
down
yeah some some teachers are heroes
that's true i talked to a few of them
yesterday teachers with moral courage
who stand against the abuse and the
indoctrination of children they're
heroes
teachers in general though are just
people some of them are heroes some of
them are simpering cowards and lazy
do-nothings who got a year off of work
and still wanted more
some are propagandists and partisans
some are much worse than that so it's a
mixed bag
but what you can't do is put everybody
into the bag and label the whole bag
heroes
more to the point mcauliffe says that
parents
shouldn't be telling teachers what to
teach
well then who should be telling them
what to teach
who who should be deciding ultimately
what kids are taught
what they learn
what values are instilled
this is not a question about the rights
of teachers it's not it's not a question
about teachers at all
this is a question about who should have
the primary authority
over children
and there are really only two possible
answers to that
at least their own they're only there
there are only two that are ever
given
it becomes a binary choice it's either
going to be
the state
or the parents
mcauliffe says the state the loudoun
county school board certainly thinks the
answer is the state
more specifically they think the answer
is them personally as representatives of
the state
so that could be your answer
that the state has ultimate authority
over children which again is what this
is about
who is in charge of children another way
of putting it is who do the children
belong to
first and foremost
on earth anyway
you know as as uh believers we would say
that the the children belong to god
first and foremost but who who has god
um
given that authority to on earth who has
god primarily entrusted those children
to
the state or the parents
and we know that the state has been
raising its hand for decades and saying
no no it's us it's us give us your kids
and for a very long time parents were
happy to just
even if they didn't agree to sort of go
along with that
and usher their children into the arms
of the state and say hey treat them well
now
i'll i'll trust you to have their best
interests at heart
now i think people are finally waking up
to the truth
and that is a
a very good thing
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if you spend time on the
internet as we all do of course because
that's where you are right now you
should know that uh you are potentially
vulnerable and that's why you need
lifelock payment apps even like you know
venmo cash app and others make payments
easy but you may want to adjust your
privacy settings to prevent them from
sharing your personal information a
recent report found that payment apps
share user data with third parties such
as banks fraud monitoring services and
some even share with marketing firms
that's just one example of the ways that
people can get a hold of your
information and another reason why again
you need lifelock every day we put our
information at risk on the internet in
an instant a cyber criminal could harm
what's yours your finances your credit
your reputation
and that's why it's so good that we have
lifelock health detect a wide range of
identity threats uh things that you may
not know about or may not have access to
information you may not have access to
unless you have life lock you also have
access to a dedicated restoration
specialist if you do become a victim
nobody can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep what's yours
with lifelock by norton join now and
save up to 25
off your first year at lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com walsh for 25
off well a little bit of
uh personal
news
and
sad family news in fact i have to tell
you about um unfortunately
we we did suffer
a tragedy in our home
because we uh we finally got a dog and
i've i've told you there that i've been
with
trying to withstand this pressure
campaign from my wife and my kids
and i i
i stood up to it for as long as i could
okay
i i endured it for as long as i possibly
could but finally i i gave in
and we've now adopted
some kind of dog i don't even know what
this beast is that's in our house
i don't know what kind of dog it is it's
just there hanging out
and uh it you know for for the most part
it hasn't been as bad as i expected
because the dog's pretty calm
um he doesn't jump on the furniture so
far he doesn't he doesn't like chew
pillows and stuff like that
uh although really if you started
chewing pillows i think i'd be fine with
that because we have way too many of
those in the house it might be a good
thing
but
the worst thing about having the dog so
far is that is that we have become the
sort of family and when i say we have
become a sort of family this is really
like 100 my wife but we become the sort
of family where that that takes 20
pictures of the dog every day
and like sends it around to family
members
and group text messages so look what our
dog did
look what our dog just did isn't this
cute
i'm looking at all these text messages
my wife is sending with pictures of the
dog and i'm thinking to myself what have
we become
i don't recognize this anymore
maybe there's a little bit of jealousy
too because i i'm getting this feeling
like i've been replaced by the dog in
some ways
like the other day just on sunday before
i left uh the kids were going to the
park and uh and i wasn't able to go
excited to finish up some work
and they came to me they said dad are
you
are you coming to the park and i said
well i can't because i got to finish
some work they said oh let's
oh okay
well can the dog come yeah they could
come yay and they just ran off what do
you need dad for when you got the dog
it's a tragedy this is what we are now
all right so the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff general mark milley
testified before the senate armed
services committee tom cotton asked him
the question that we've all had which is
why hasn't he resigned
given that the afghan afghanistan
withdrawal was a was a tremendous
disaster that killed uh resulted in the
deaths of of
many people not even counting the seven
children and three uh adults who were
murdered via drone strike
with claims that they were terrorists
and it turns out they weren't
so why is this guy still in a position
of power why hasn't he resigned
here's his answer to that question
as a senior military officer
resigning is a really serious thing it's
a political act if i'm resigning in
protest my job is to provide advice my
statutory responsibilities provide legal
advice or best military advice to the
president and that's my legal
requirement that's what the law is
the president doesn't have to agree with
that advice he doesn't have to make
those decisions
just because we're generals
and it would be an incredible
act of political defiance for a
commissioned officer to just resign
because my advice is not taken this
country doesn't want generals
figuring out what orders we're going to
accept and do or not that's not our job
the principle of civilian control of the
military is absolute it's critical to
this republic in addition to that just
from a personal standpoint you know my
my dad didn't get a choice to resign at
iwo jima and those kids there at abby
gate they don't get a choice to resign
and i'm not going to turn my back on
them uh
i'm not going to resign they can't
resign so i'm not going to resign
there's no way
yeah that kind of misses the point
doesn't it
i mean that's that's that's not the
that's not the point we're not we're not
saying that you should
resign in protest
okay we're we're saying it's not that
you should resign in protest because
other people screwed up and you're upset
about it
it's that you screwed up and that's why
you should be gone because you're
incompetent
and much of what's happening right now
is your fault
so
i feel like someone had to clear that
confusion up for him
um
similar confusion here
political controversy i'm reading now
from the from the daily wire it says
republican governor christie gnome on
tuesday
slammed the media for trying to destroy
her children following a report from the
associated press claiming that nobe
engaged in a conflict of interest
a claim the governor's office uh has
denied as a holy political attack
the associated press reported on tuesday
just days after a south dakota agency
moved to deny her daughter's application
to become a certified real estate
appraiser governor christie gnomes
summoned to her office the state
employee who ran the agency the women's
direct supervisor and the state labor
secretary gnome's daughter attended two
cassidy peters then 26 ultimately
obtained the certification in november
of 2020 four months after the meeting at
her mother's office
peters told the ap my upgrade to become
a certified residential appraiser was
very lengthy and i was expected to
navigate through many obstacles from the
very beginning i'm glad i have it now
and that i have the privilege to serve
my clients in south dakota uh so this is
this is the claim anyway from from the
associated press that christy gnome
used the power of her office to get this
position for her daughter so some some
nepotism there
and if if it's true that she did this
and i don't know if it's true or not
there would be quite a lot of irony and
hypocrisy in that because you know this
is the same woman
who has refused
for example to step up and prevent
employers from firing employees in the
state if they're not vaccinated and she
and she she refused to um
prevent
you know colleges from
allowing
men on to the on to the female sports
teams
uh she went along with the trans agenda
the re and the reason she did all of
that or she didn't do any of that rather
is because she she felt that it would be
an inappropriate use of state power
and it would be it would be wrong for
her to use her power in that way that's
that was the reason she gave
so if she's saying that it would be an
inappropriate use of state power to
stand up for the rights
of the citizens of her state and yet
she's using her power in this way that
would be quite a lot of irony hypocrisy
in that but this is where this was her
response
um
she says
i posted this to twitter she says listen
i get it
i signed up for this job but now the
media is trying to destroy my children
the story is just another example of the
double standard that exists with the
media going after conservatives and
their kids while ignoring liberals
hashtag ask the big guy
now i'm just looking if there's more to
this because that first of all that's
not exactly a denial is it
i don't see that as a denial and also it
once again purposefully misses the point
just like with mark milley now we're not
saying you that you should resign in
protest of other people screwing up
we're saying that you're the screw-up
you're the incompetent you're unfit for
the office and that's why you need to be
gone in this case no no one's attacking
your your child who's an adult by the
way
uh what they're attacking you they're
saying that you acted inappropriately
so if you use the power of your office
in this nepotistic way to
secure a position for your daughter
and we say we disapprove of that we're
not attacking your daughter as you well
know
so i don't know if this is true or not i
of course i can't i can't say that
but it does make me kind of suspicious
that this was christie noem's response
there's no denial in it
and she's intentionally missing the
point
that that always makes me suspicious
because joe biden as she references in
the hashtag
i'm sure if i went back and looked i
could see examples of christinome
criticizing joe biden because of the
hunter biden stuff
i don't know that for sure but i'm going
to guess that i could
and what has been joe biden's response
to all the criticisms of how he
allegedly used the power of his office
to secure favors and positions for
hunter biden his response has been stop
attacking my family you're attacking my
kids
my precious little child my little boy
who's in his 50s or 40s or whatever
so she's using the exact same approach
here which just makes me suspicious
i'm also suspicious of this person
stephanie grisham reading now from the
hill it says former white house press
secretary stephanie grisham claimed in a
new book that she sought to shield a
young female aide from former president
trump after he at one point invited her
to his air force cabin to
look at her
grisham writes in her new book i'll take
her questions now set to be released on
october 5th that she tried to keep a
young female aide away from trump after
the former president repeatedly invited
her up to his air force one cabin
including one time to look at her and
used an expletive to describe her rear
end
grisham also writes that trump told her
to promote the aid and keep her happy
according to the new york times which
received a manuscript of grisham's book
and i'm not gonna go on reading that
because i because i don't really care
this is always my problem with these
tell-all books after the fact
if you have a bunch of
deep dirty dark secrets that you can
tell
and you held on to all those secrets
and you continued working for this
person for years
just so that once they're out of power
you can write your tell-all book and get
a big advance and make a lot of money
off the royalties
then i'm automatically going to be
suspicious of of of that as well
and the other interesting thing about
these um
these revelations about donald trump
we've seen so many tell all books about
donald trump
with either anonymous revelations people
who
claim to be so deeply concerned about
what trump did and and
when he was off in office and all of his
alleged abuses of power that they remain
anonymous they won't put their name
behind the accusations
or people who wait until they're gone
they work for trump for years oftentimes
wait until they're fired and then they
come out with the tell-all
um
but what you find is that is that uh
most of the time these accusations and
these revelations if they're even true
do not at all live up to
what you would expect given what the
media tells us about donald trump donald
trump they tell us that he's a he he's
literally hitler he's a dictator he's
evil incarnate
this power mad megalomaniac a threat to
our republic a threat to democracy
they they again put him on they very
explicitly put him on par with the great
monsters of history pol pot hitler
stalin
i'm not even sure if they would call
stalin a monster at this point uh but
and then hit and then and then donald
trump goes goes right in that same
that's unholy mount rushmore i suppose
and yet
in all of these tell-all books and all
these revelations
all we ever really hear is about donald
trump saying being kind of a jerk and a
jackass and a boar and being a pig
allegedly
using inappropriate language
that's the most we ever hear
at worst that's who donald trump is
which is what i kind of expected him
always to be
you never get the kind of revelations
that live up to the uh
live up to the billing from the
democrats all right next greta
thunderberg was speaking at some kind of
another climate summit so we've got
basically there's a new climate summit
every week every two weeks and this was
youth four climates
and uh greta thunderberg i thought made
a very eloquent case for protecting the
environment listen to this
there is no planet b
there is no planet blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah
this is not about some expensive
politically correct green act of bunny
hugging or blah blah blah
build back better blah blah blah green
economy blah blah blah
net zero by 2050 blah blah blah net zero
blah blah blah climate neutral blah blah
blah that's where we are now that's the
point we've reached
where greta thumber can get up in front
of an audience
a crowd of hundreds of people and
literally just say blah blah blah
and uh and that becomes an applause line
that was an actual applause line
in fact i think the
the the transcript there she said planet
blah blah blah blah
what
what it doesn't mean anything
that of course means nothing
and that was a rousing applause line
from the people in the in the audience
this this is one of the things that
sometimes makes me want to become
you know a leftist because you it's it's
very easy to impress people
when you're speaking to that crowd
very a very easily impressed crowd
very easy to pander to
you don't even have to say words anymore
you could just stand in front of there
you know i do a lot of public speaking
uh you know i give a lot a lot of
speeches and
i i always feel this pressure this
enormous pressure you know you're
standing in front of a crowd to say
something meaningful you know i'll
actually write
like real words onto
a page and i'll you know read the words
but to be able to stand there and simply
say blah blah blah and that's your
speech that is pretty amazing here's a
video that's gone viral thanks as always
to the iconic libs of tick tock twitter
account
except this isn't a lib this is a black
teacher from california i think this is
this video is from a couple of months
ago i think
because she's no longer a teacher
anymore she's left
but she's doing an unboxing video as the
kids call it showing us uh what gift her
school district gave to her
and it would seem all of the black
educators
this is the the little gift basket they
were given watch
last year i
went to go pick up this gift from the
district thinking maybe it's a i was
already pretty insulted by it but i
wanted to see what it was and so i went
and picked it up from the district
because we were of course teaching
online the whole year and i um
i
got this i picked up the gift
and here it is right here
um in it was of course the black
educators matter mask which i would
never wear in front of my students
imagine if someone wore a white
educators matter mask
my god
patronizing insulting
degrading
this is why i always say as a
you know i know that as a as a white man
the left hates me
i'm i'm the as a as a white quote
unquote cis man
um
i'm the villain right i'm the uber
villain and i understand that
and but i would i would much rather be
in that position
and be treated that way
than be infantilized like this
i really think in a lot of ways i have
it better i would rather just be
insulted
and have you tell me that that i'm a
scumbag and i'm a horrible person
that to be treated like a like a child
like a
a dumb child
infantilized and degraded
but it has this because it has the same
effect in the end it's just as insulting
but at least with me they're going to be
pretty straightforward about it and just
say we hate you you're horrible okay
good fine
and also we've got this i don't know if
you're ready for some comedy but check
this out from stephen colbert's show
this i'm not sure when this aired we'll
only play this there's there's not a big
audio component of this so only play a
few seconds of it but this was uh i
guess a comedy bit on stephen colbert's
show
where they he he brings on a bunch of
people dressed like giant vaccine
needles
and they dance through the crowd
doing the cha-cha to a song about the
vaccine just watch this
[Music]
let's see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
vaccine
[Music]
so let me tell you my my conspiracy
theory this this is my
this is mike it's this is my preferred
conspiracy theory
uh
when i see videos like that which i
guess
i can only assume based on
context the context of this being on a
late night alleged comedy show i can
only assume that there are that they're
trying to accomplish two things with
that
with that bit
uh one is they're trying to be funny i
guess
again i can only assume
and also they're they're trying to
promote the vaccine
but when i see
this and i see
really every effort that's been made to
promote the vaccine
by the media by hollywood by government
by my biden administration
and and almost all of them are as cringy
inducing as that or worse
when i see that i think you know this is
all part of a plan to make people more
vaccine hesitant
this this is there's not much of a
conspiracy theory i think it's just
become an obvious conclusion that we
have to draw
so i
watch that and i think well there's
there's no way that they think that's
actually going to reach anybody who
hasn't been vaccinated
the only thing you can hope is that the
most die-hard vaccine cultists will will
see that and maybe they'll be pleased by
it and they'll get up and they'll start
dancing
in their living room or something
but there's just no way that they think
that anyone who's vaccine hesitant is
going to see that and say you know what
after seeing these dancing vaccine
needles
uh with stephen colbert doing the
cha-cha down the aisle
on a late night show i think i think
it's time i think i'll go out and get
the job i think i'll go out and put this
you have convinced me to put this
substance into my body i was hesitant
about it i wasn't sure
but now yeah i'll do it
it's clearly not going to have that
effect and i don't i don't believe that
they think that
i think they're trying i think they
don't want those people to get
vaccinated
the unvaccinated the anti-vaxxers they
provide a good foil they're they're a
good villain group a very um
useful
villain group
for the left and for the media
and they want it to stay that way
and all of their all of the failed
policies that are supposed to
you know stop the spread of the virus
every single policy has failed
going back to 15 days to slow the spread
up until now
but now they have a group that they can
blame
even though these policies have been
failing all along
and they tell us that vaccinated people
are also spreading the virus that's what
they tell us
but it gives them a handy group that
they can blame and i think they want
that group to stay there
that's my theory
all right this is from cnbc um
amazon has announced a home robot called
astro astro is equipped with a rotating
screen that's mounted onto a base with
wheels amazon designed the robot to
appear animated and friendly with eyes
and expressive body movements that
respond to user interaction
the robot can move on its own from room
to room and is capable of navigating
around objects on the floor or breaking
to avoid colliding with obstacles such
as a pet that moves into its path
a periscope camera attached to the base
of the device can be raised or lowered
to view objects that are high up so this
is a
this is a little robot like r2d2 thing
that i guess you're supposed to have in
your house and it'll it'll follow you
around the house it has a camera and it
can respond to you
and it could also spy on you and see
everything in your house which is the
real reason why amazon wants to put this
out there i just think i see all of
these these new innovations and i and i
know and apparently this is gonna be on
sale for a thousand dollars which is
less than i thought it would be it's not
on sale yet but when it is
we all know there's gonna be lines
around the block to buy this damn thing
and all of the people who are lining up
to spend a thousand dollars of money
they don't have
uh to to put a a spy robot into their
home along with all the other spy robots
they already have in their home
every single one of them if you ask them
they'll tell you that they are deeply
concerned with their privacy
and they're very worried about big tech
spying on them
the privacy is
you you go up to that line of people and
ask every single one of them how
important is privacy to you is it is
that a big priority of yours oh yeah
absolutely
i'm very concerned with my own privacy
while they have an apple watch on
they're getting the robot to spy on them
they already have alexa
there's there's a there's a real
disconnect there i think all right let's
move now to reading the comments
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
and badger boy says quoting uh one of
the women in that news report that we
played during the cancellation yesterday
if you don't have a kid at the school
why would you want to testify badger boy
says someone should tell her the vast
majority of school board members do not
have kids at the school they sit on the
board for that's a very good point
that's a point that i i think i have
missed myself and haven't brought up
very often but yes that's an excellent
point
on these these not just aladdin county
but school boards all across the country
your own school board
go take a look sometime and see how many
of the people on that board actually
have kids in the district
some of them are childless some of them
have kids that have long since grown up
i mean oftentimes they'll have they'll
have kids school-aged kids but they put
their own kids in private school
uh
and king of cali says matt's first job
was retrieving carts his discuss with
people leaving their carts makes sense
now yeah that is my that's my origin
it's my villain oh no that's my no
that's my superhero origin story
because i am a superhero when it comes
to carts anyway
that is a real
that is that is where i think i
demonstrate heroism in my life
um
and another comment says matt trying to
camouflage with his hotel surroundings
is actually quite an endearing quality
despite it being as aesthetically
jarring
my style choices i mean endearing is a
word you could use for them i've heard
i've heard many other words
that are
not quite as complimentary but thank you
for that
uh sp2 says matt between this and abuela
you've reached legend trolling status
why well thank you thank you for that
and i will tell you that
when it comes to to that
we've got more where that is where that
comes from we're upping the ante i can't
say anything else other than that but
just stay tuned is all i'm going to say
and ej says i like how matt is bragging
about the fact that he's virginia now
like it's some sort of badge of honor
it is a badge of honor
okay ej when it's your truth
okay when it's when it's when it's
something that you've wanted deep down
in your bones
for as long as you can remember to be a
resident of virginia it is something to
brag about
thank you very much and you're banned
from the show
uh
scott says i hope matt isn't going to
wear skinny jeans to the school board
meeting because the people behind him
won't be able to listen to him without
being distracted if he is well
scott i don't wear skinny jeans to your
band from the show but also there was
nobody behind me in the school board
meeting because they don't let the
public remember they don't let the
public into the building to actually
hear the comments you don't have to
worry about that at all uh
and finally crystal says matt you should
start a side gig as a consultant people
could contact you if they get carried
before they make a statement on their
social media
you could call yourself the sweet baby
justice warrior
uh i don't think anybody would hire me
as a pr consultant but i will tell you
that i think most pr consultants are are
terrible at their job because they want
to keep their job and so
you know
the real pr advice to for for many
people who find themselves in the middle
of some big controversy and the you know
the social media mobs coming after them
the lynch mobs coming after them
in many cases
what they should do especially if it's a
public figure
all you have to do is say nothing at all
just remain quiet
and wait for it to go away and then
pretend it never happened
because the mob almost always moves on
to the next target
that's the one thing you have going in
your favor
is that yeah it's overwhelming in the
moment
but these people have the memories and
the attention span of fruit flies and
they're gonna move on to the next target
so just don't say anything
but i think pr consultants if they give
that advice if they get the advice of oh
don't say anything
then it's like what do we need you for
so they have to
you know they have to
justify their jobs by crafting some sort
of statement it's like here's what our
strategy is going to be
so if i was a pr consultant that's all i
would say
i'd charge you a thousand dollars and i
would say okay good just don't say
anything
and you'll be fine
i consider myself to be something of a
fitness guru that might be overstating
it dramatically maybe not a fitness guru
but i do think it's important to stay in
good shape and that's why i'm very happy
to have planet fitness now as sponsors
of the show you can work out your stress
and get back to feeling great at planet
fitness you can join the judgment-free
zone today for just ten dollars a month
and get tons of cardio and strength
and strength of equipment in our clean
and spacious clubs with free fitness
training and plenty of room to move you
can go at your own pace and get back to
a routine that works for you
all for just ten dollars a month and
that's one of the most important things
is to find a routine that works for you
and just stick to it uh don't wait join
any of our 2000 plus locations today in
club online or on the app see club for
details
all right let's get now to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we must
cancel will smith we could cancel him
because he hasn't made a good movie in
20 years but his filmography isn't the
topic of contention today our focus now
is on smith's recent interview in gq
where he discusses the beauty and wonder
of being in an open marriage
will smith is in an open marriage with
his wife jada pinkett smith though it
appears that the marriage was initially
opened
against his will um the couple
infamously sat across from each other
for a red table talk on facebook last
year where they awkwardly in front of
the cameras
discussed an affair that jada had years
before um
i've never been able to watch more than
a minute of this conversation because
the cringe factor is so overwhelming but
just to refresh our memories here's a
little bit of that discussion watch this
you
[Music]
during that time launched into an
interaction
with august what do you feel like
you were looking for
i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good
and it was really a joy
to just
help heal somebody yeah
i think that has a lot to do with my
codependency
which is another thing that i had to
learn to break in this cycle just that
idea of needing to fix and being drawn
to people that need help whether it's
your health or whether it's your
addictions there's something about
that childhood trauma
um
that
feels as though it can be fixed
through
fixing people
yeah well that's one way to put it she
she was not starting an affair she was
as well puts it launching into an
interaction
there's some nice euphemistic language
that you might want to try if you're a
dirty rotten cheater caught in the act
oh no honey i wasn't cheating i was
really just i was having an interaction
you know we kind of launched into this
interaction there was an exchange you
might say
an understanding was reached
a meeting of the minds and of other
parts
of course i'm imagining the cheater
making the excuses for themselves here
but actually will smith is the one
providing the euphemisms to the wife who
cheated on him and for her part she's a
little bit more direct because he asks
what were you looking for when you
cheated on me and she says i just wanted
to feel good
and he says oh okay
as if that sheds comforting new light on
the situation but obviously she cheated
because it made her feel good that's why
any cheater cheats it's why any bad
person does anything bad that's the
motivating factor behind all sin you do
it because it makes you feel good and
you have prioritized feeling good over
all other concerns especially your
commitments your promises your moral
obligations that's why every bad person
does bad things
so that was last year now will smith is
in gq talking about his free and open
marriage and how happy and loving it all
is reading from the daily wire report it
says
uh quote jaina never believed in
conventional marriage smith told gq jada
had family members that had an
unconventional relationship so she grew
up in a way that was very different than
how i grew up there were significant
endless discussions about what is
relational perfection smith recalled and
for the large part of our relationship
monogamy was that choi
choice not thinking of monogamy as the
only relational perfection the pair have
given each other trust and freedom
within the relationship page six noted
uh since marriage can't be a prison will
smith said
quote i don't suggest our road for
anybody i don't suggest this road for
anybody but the experience is that the
freedoms that we've given one another
and the unconditional support to me is
the highest definition of love
it was a lot of that was quite
incoherent but hopefully you basically
got the idea the highest definition of
love is betrayal he says or rather it's
it's doing what makes you feel good
individually
in other words the highest love in a
marriage is self-interest
that is what will smith proposes and
what makes it all the sadder and more
pitiable is that you can tell he doesn't
really believe a word of what he's
saying this is how these open marriages
work there's usually one member of the
couple who feels betrayed and is being
betrayed it has to convince themselves
that they're not being betrayed
when you listen to the stories of
couples and open marriages you always
hear either the husband or the wife say
yeah you know my spouse decided that
it'd be a good idea for them to sleep
with other people and you know i was
utterly and completely devastated and
destroyed by it at first but over time
i've learned to accept it and i'm really
so happy now
when i'm not locking myself in the
bathroom and weeping uncontrollably five
times a day
an open marriage is after all
betrayal as a lifestyle
and betrayal doesn't become any less
traitorous just because it's done in the
open
that actually makes it worse if anything
because now you've enlisted your spouse
to be an accomplice in your infidelity
you don't even have the decency to cheat
in secret and save them the indignity
and the shame of pretending that they're
okay with it
an open marriage is also an oxymoron
it's a contradiction in terms it's like
open borders
if you open a border then it's not a
border anymore if you open a marriage
and it's not a marriage anymore a
marriage by definition is closed a
marriage can't be opened for the same
reason that you know you can't build a
house without walls or a roof the walls
in the roof are the whole point of the
house get rid of those and now you're
homeless
a blanket laid out on the pavement is
not an open house or a new house or a
consensually non-walled house
it's just not a house it's a non-house
it's literally the opposite of a house
and if we start calling that a house
then we haven't expanded the definition
of a house but instead we've done away
with the very concept of a house
entirely and i think that would be a
very stupid thing to do because houses
are very useful things to have just like
marriages
marriage has its own walls and its own
roof and it's within those walls and
under that roof that your family must be
formed and maintained monogamy is but
one of the bricks used to build this
structure
uh
procreativity is another which also has
been largely abandoned by our culture
but these building blocks are the only
things that make a marital union
distinct from any other kind of union
they're the whole point of marriage
to decide on open marriages to tear down
the walls of your house and take shelter
in the rubble and the fact that the
adultery is mutually agreed upon and
consensual doesn't make it any less
adulterous or any better at all really
our culture has developed this idea that
it's okay to commit an evil action if
we're open and honest about it
but that so-called honesty is born from
your pride and your lack of concern for
how your wickedness will hurt those
closest to you
at least a man who hides his affair has
acknowledged first that it's base and
shameful and second that it's harmful to
his family but somebody who advertises
infidelity is a sociopath with no shame
he's much further from redemption i
think in his marriage much further from
healing than the guy who claims that
he's staying late for work so that he
can meet his mistress at a motel 6.
i mean it's all bad in the end
of course
and it's why fidelity is the much better
course
that's where you have a real marriage
a loving marriage a marriage that is
actually a marriage
and that is why will smith today much
like his marriage i must say is canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike cormina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
the democrat governor of virginia says
parents have no right to educate their
kids joe biden yet again moves the goal
posts on reopening society and joe
biden's generals testify under oath that
he lied about the lead-up to the
withdrawal from afghanistan check it out
on the michael knowles show